this is uh from reuters it says facebook
incorporated's oversight board on
wednesday upheld the company's
suspension of former u.s president
donald trump
but said the company was wrong to make
the suspension indefinite and gave it
six months to determine a proportionate
response
trump called the decision and his
banning across tech platforms a total
disgrace and said the companies would
pay a political price
um and uh so he's he's still banned at
least for six months
and trump is upset about that and says
they're gonna pay a price right well
first of all the two things here it it
obviously is absurd
to ban the former president um
from any social media platform
especially all of them as he currently
is
it's absurd it's it's it's uh
dangerous it's pretty terrifying the
kind of power these platforms have
to have to have effectively erased
a former president he leaves office and
he's gone
um and that's why they're doing it and i
think i think everyone knows that
even if they won't admit it this is this
is obviously politically motivated
and they don't want to give him the
platform back especially if he's
thinking about running again
in 2024 um because
and they also don't want to be blamed by
the media
yeah i think if if facebook and twitter
let donald trump back on
and then he runs in 2024 and wins
they're gonna get blamed for that by by
the sorts of people that they don't want
blaming them for things
so the whole thing is is totally wrong
however
the reason why i can't generate a lot of
anger and outrage over this
to the same degree as other
conservatives and other in other you
know conservatives and media especially
very very upset about the trump facebook
ban and all of that
i can't get myself to feel all that
upset about it because
as i have argued many times trump
had the chance to do something to rein
in big tech and he didn't do
anything or even try
and so now he he's he's here he is
impotent
and powerless hanging out at mar-a-lago
promising that they're gonna pay a price
no they're not gonna pay a price
actually
you have no power right now none
doesn't matter what you say
you could have made them pay a price
when you were the president of the
united states
republicans could have done something
when they controlled the entire
government
with trump at the top of it for two
years
they didn't do anything nothing what did
they do
during those two years when they
controlled the whole government what did
they do about big tech did they do
anything
nothing no not just about big tech
they didn't do anything about anything
they just didn't do it they passed a tax
cut
that's what they did well done fellas
great job
gave us a tax cut
and that was it with republican
control of congress for two years and
then republican control of the white
house for four years
what do we get at the end of it we get
uh tax cuts
and then some other policies all of
which have been were erased by the biden
administration
like that gone
as far as making making a lasting impact
doing something big and important
and difficult like reigning in big tech
for example
didn't even try they talked about it
republicans are talking about it again
now when they have no power to do it
that's that's that is the republican
move it's to wait until you have no
power
and then to start talking a big game
about all these things ah let me add
them
if all yeah let you know it's it is it's
like
it's like the the kid in high school
or middle school you know who starts
talking a big game
in class acting like he wants to fight
another kid
when the teacher is right there and he
knows the teacher is going to stop him
and then you find that kid outside of
the classroom like at the bus stop and
he's he's running for the hills
that's what the republican party is
that's what they are
they talk a big game they become big
tough fighters and warriors when they
know they can't do a damn thing anyway
because they got the teacher in the
class that's going to stop them
put them in charge of the class they
actually have some authority now
and they become pushovers biding their
time until they have no authority again
so yeah i'm not i'm not in the mood to
cry any tears for
any of them
this is what happens
you fed the alligator and then it ate
you like
that's that's that's how that goes
listen hit that subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated